بعد شهر سبتمبر ايلول الذي اعتبر الاكثر
سخونه على الاطلاق يبدا شهر اكتوبر تشرين
الاول بدرجات حراره تزيد عن 30 مئويه في
جوند اكبر اقاليم فرنسا في عاصمه الاقليم
بغدو يبحث السكان عن فيء شجره يستظلون به
من حراره اكتوبر غير
المعتاده المنطقه كان لدينا دائما فتره جو
دافئ في اواخر الخريف لكن صحيح ان هناك
بضع درجات اضافيه الان ليس هناك موسم ليس
هناك شتاء هناك صيف ربما كل شيء مختلط
اليوم هيئه الارصاد الجويه الفرنسيه ذكرت
ان متوسط درجه الحراره في سبتمبر في
البلاد كان نحو 2 درجه وهو معدل يفوق
بثلاث درجات ونصف معدل الفتره المرجعيه ما
بين اعوام 91 من القرن الماضي و
2020 وقالت الهيئه ان موجات الحر تحدث
الان ايضا خارج اشهر الصيف المرتفعه
المعتاده في شهري يوليو واغسطس ونراها في
سبتمبر وحتى اكتوبر وفي الربيع وعادت
حراره الصيف الى اسبانيا خلال الشهر
الجاري مما ادى الى درجات حراره غير عاديه
في جميع انحاء البلاد وافادت وكاله
الارصاد الجويه الاسبانيه ان درجه الحراره
وصلت الى
35 في نهايه الاسبوع الجاري في العاصمه
مدريد بما يفوق المعدل الطبيعيه لهذا
الوقت من العام بنحو ع درجات مئويه مع
تعرض بعض اجزاء البلاد لخطر الحرائق
الشديد واعلنت بلجيكا والنمسا والمانيا
وبولندا وسويسرا عن احر سبتمبر على
الاطلاق وجاء الطقس الدافئ غير المعتاد في
اوروبا بعد ان قالت خدمه كوبرنيكوس لتغير
المناخ التابعه للاتحاد الاوروبي في وقت
سابق من الشهر الماضي ان عام
2023 من المرجح ان يكون العام الاكثر
حراره تشهده البشريه يقول العلماء ان تغير
المناخ يؤدي الى ارت درجات الحراره
العالميه حيث بلغت نحو درجه و2 درجه فوق
مستويات ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه ومن
المرجح ان تلوح درجات الحراره المرتفعه في
الافق للتو مع بدء ظاهره النينيو الجويه
التي تعمل على تسخين المياه في جنوب
المحيط الهادئ
وخارجه